My cousin Nadia is taking a
summer calculus course and
she called me last night.
And she had some limit
problems and they were
excellent problem.
So I thought it was worthwhile
to make videos on the problems
that she had to figure out.
Anyway, so let's do them.
If I remember them correctly.
I'm doing this on memory.
So I hope the answers work out
like they did last night when
we were going over
them on the phone.
So if I remember correctly,
the first one was the limit
as z approaches 2 of x.
Oh no.
Not that-- There's no x.
It's a z.
Of z squared plus 2z minus 8.
All of that over z to
the fourth minus 16.
So the first thing when you
want to do when you try a limit
problem is, well you just try
to substitute the value into--
Maybe there's no problem when z
equals 2 and you just evaluate
the function at z equals 2.
If it's a continuous function,
then the limit as z
approaches 2 is going to
be the function at 2.
But you immediately see a
problem if you put 2 right
here-- 2 to the fourth minus
16 --and you get a 0 in the
denominator, which is
undefined, so we have to
figure out some way
to get around that.
And nine times out of 10, when
you see a problem like this,
the solution, because both the
numerator and the denominator
look factorable, is to factor
the numerator and
the denominator.
So this is equal to the
limit as z approaches 2.
What's the numerator factored?
Let's see.
Something when you add two
numbers, you get positive
2, and you multiply
them, you get minus 8.
So it's probably plus
4 and minus 2, right?
So this is going to
be x plus-- No.
Not an x.
I'm so conditioned.
I'm like a dog.
Oh.
I can't even undo it anymore.
Anyway, well z-- Actually
let me erase that.
I don't want to be messy.
Let me erase.
I tried to undo it and it
doesn't remember everything.
So it's z plus 4
times z minus 2.
That's just factoring
a quadratic.
And what is this?
This has the form a squared
minus b squared, right?
So that's going to be-- But a
squared-- If this is a squared
minus b squared, a would
be z squared, right?
So it's z squared plus 4
times z squared minus 4.
And then, of course, this
also has the form a squared
plus b squared, right?
So this will further factor
into z plus 2 times z minus 2.
Well, our factoring paid off.
We see a term in the numerator
and the denominator
that are the same.
And not only are they the
same, but they-- This is
the term that was giving
us the problems, right?
Because you put a 2 in
here, you got a 0.
So let's assume that we're not
evaluating it at z equals 2.
And so, for all other
values, we can divide those
because those are going
to be the same values.
And then what are we left with?
This is equal to the limit--
and I've change colors
arbitrarily --as z approaches
2 of z plus 4 over z squared
plus 4 times z plus 2.
Which is equal what?
That's equal to 6 over--
what's 2 squared plus 4?
Is 8.
And then 2 plus 2 is 4.
6 over 12 is equal to 1/2.
There you go.
I thought that was a pretty
interesting problem.
Let's do another one.
And this one I found
even more interesting.
She gave me-- It's really
testing my memory to see
if I can-- But I remember
the gist of the problem.
So I might not get the exact
numbers she'd given me, but
hopefully I get the
exact properties.
So it's the limit as x
approaches infinity of the
square root of x squared
plus 4x plus 1 minus x.
So when you look at this
you're like well let's see.
What's happening here?
Let's see this.
As you go to infinity, this
term will get really big.
But then we're taking
the square root of it.
And it seems like this term
would overpower this term.
And then, so maybe this kind
of converges to x, but then
we would subtract an x.
So maybe it approaches 0.
So that's, at least, that
was my first intuition
when I spoke to her.
But as we will see, the
intuition here is wrong.
And really to do this you
have to know a little
bit of a trick.
And this trick pays off a lot
whenever you see something with
the square root sign, then
subtracting something else, if
you want to get rid of
that square root sign.
So what we are going to do is
going to multiply-- Essentially
the conjugate we normally
apply to complex numbers.
But if we have something like
a plus b, the conjugate
is a minus b, right?
Or if we have something
like a minus b, the
conjugate is a plus b.
And the reason why-- And what
we're going to do is we're
going to multiply by
the conjugate of this.
And why does-- Why
is that normal?
Why is that useful?
Because we have a minus b.
If we multiply it times a
plus b, we get a squared
minus b squared.
Which will make this radical
sign disappear without
too much work.
So let's do that.
Let's multiply by the
conjugate of this thing.
But we can't just
multiply it, right?
We have to multiply it
by it over itself.
Because you can only-- To not
change the value of something,
you can only multiply it by 1.
So let's multiply it by the
conjugate: x squared plus
4x plus 1 plus x, right?
That's the conjugate, right?
Instead of minus x,
we have a plus x.
And we can't just
multiply that.
We have to multiply it by
1, otherwise we would
be changing the value.
So it's going to be divided
by the same thing.
x squared plus 4x
plus 1 plus x.
Let me erase this stuff
down here so we don't
get distracted.
Don't want to get distracted.
And so what do we have?
This will become the limit
as x approaches infinity.
Well, this is a minus
b times a plus b.
So we end up with a squared.
Well, what's this squared?
That's x squared plus 4x
plus 1 minus b squared.
Well what's b squared?
Well, b is x.
So it's going to be
minus x squared.
This is just algebra.
Divided by this thing: the
square root of x squared
plus 4x plus 1 plus x.
So let's see.
There's a little
simplification we can do.
We can subtract-- We can--
These top two terms cancel out.
So x squared minus x squared.
And now let's see
what we can do.
Well since we're taking x
to infinity, and this is
what you normally do what
you take x to infinity.
We can divide the numerator
and the denominator by
our highest degree term.
And in this case, our highest
degree terms is x, right?
We have an x here
and an x here.
And then when you take-- And
then, of course, when you
divide something like this
by x, and you take it to,
infinity, this will approach 0.
So let's do that.
Let's divide the numerator
and the denominator by x.
And remember: anything you do
in the numerator, you have
to do in the denominator.
Otherwise you're
changing the value.
So times 1 over x
over 1 over x.
I'm just dividing the numerator
and the denominator by x.
So this is equal to the limit
as x approaches infinity of--
What's-- That's going to
be 4 plus 1 over x over--
Let me ask you a question.
What is 1 over x
times this thing?
What is-- This is a bit of an
algebra review, but 1 over x.
What's 1 over x times x
squared plus 4x plus 1?
I'm just doing a little
on the side here.
Well if we take the 1 over
x and we put it into the
radical sign, it becomes
1 over x squared, right?
This is the same thing as--
You can say 1 squared
over x squared, but--
1 over x squared.
You could say 1 squared.
You could put a square there,
but-- Times x squared
plus 4x plus 1.
And that should make
sense to you, right?
Because if we started with
this, we could easily just
take the square root of
this and take it outside.
And the square root
of this is 1 over x.
I'm just going in the
other direction, right?
So, assuming you're comfortable
with that, everything
under the radical sign.
Even though we're actually
dividing by 1 over x, since
we're going into the radical
sign, we're actually
dividing by x squared.
So it becomes-- this is the
radical sign --x squared
divided by x squared
is 1, right?
I hope you understand why we're
dividing by x squared here.
We're actually
dividing by 1 over x.
But when you put it under the
radical sign, it becomes
1 over x squared.
Let me put it this way.
1 over x times the
square root of a.
That's the same thing.
That equals the square
root of 1 squared over x
squared times a, right?
And this is just 1
over x squared.
So that's the property, or the
algebra that we're using.
So anyway, we divide all
of this by x squared.
So that becomes a 1 plus 4
over x plus 1 over x squared.
And then, of course, we divide
this one by-- This term right
here, we divide by x, right?
Because it's not in
the radical sign.
So that just becomes a 1.
So now what's the limit as
x approaches infinity?
Well as x approaches infinity,
this term right here
goes to 0, right?
1 over infinity is 0.
This term right here goes to 0.
And so what are we left with?
This is equal to 4 over the
square root of 1 plus 1.
Well that's just 1.
So that equals 4 over 2,
which is equal to 2.
There you go.
Now let's do one more problem.
This is the third
one she'd given me.
In it, we had to kind of brush
off our trig identities.
And really these harder limit
problems, they're all about
kind of knowing your algebra
and your trigonometry
really well.
Just so you know how to
manipulate these functions.
Because the limit part-- You
just have to get it into a form
where taking the limit is
fairly straightforward.
So let's do that trig problem.
Clear image.
Invert colors.
So it was the limit
as x approaches 0
of cotangent of 2x.
Was that it?
Yeah.
It was cotangent of 2x
over the cosecant of x.
And this one, just like
previous problems, more than
knowing your pre-calculus or
your calculus, you need to
know your trig identities.
So cosecant of x.
That's just 1 over sine.
I remember that by saying
it's not intuitive.
You would have thought that the
cosecant is 1 over cosine.
But it's not.
It's 1 over sine.
So I remember that
it's not intuitive.
And cotangent of 2x is equal
to 1 over tangent of 2x.
And tangent is sine over
cosine, so cotangent's
the opposite.
And so that equals cosine of
2x over sine of 2x, right?
OK.
So what is this equal to?
So this is going to be the
limit as x approaches 0.
Cotangent of 2x, we said, was
cosine of 2x over sine of 2x.
And then it's going to be all
of that over the cosecant of x.
Well that's just 1
over sine of x.
Well if you divide by 1 over
sine of x, that's the same
thing as multiplying
by sine of x.
So we have-- What do we have?
We have cosine-- Well we have
sine of x times cosine of 2x.
All of that divided
by sine of 2x.
Just doing a little arithmetic.
And we have a
problem here still.
Because when you take x
approaches 0, this term right
here goes to 0 and we have a 0
in the denominator, which
is just not acceptable.
Because it's undefined.
And that's the whole reason
why we're doing this
limit to begin with.
And actually that's the first
thing you should have done.
You should have tried to put it
and you would have seen that
you would've gotten a 0 value
in the denominator and it would
have been unevaluatable.
Right.
Because really, this is
just-- We haven't even
done any manipulation yet.
This is the same thing as this.
And if you put the 0 right
here, you get undefined.
So what can we do?
Well this is where your
break out the trig or you
brush off your memory.
What is the sine of 2x equal?
And this is your double-- One
of the double angle formulas.
Sine of 2x is equal to 2
sine of x cosine of x.
So if you know that, then
you've gone a long way because
then it becomes pretty
simple to simplify.
So it becomes 2 sine
of x cosine of x.
And if we assume that x isn't
0, it's just approaching 0, we
can divide the numerator and
the denominator by sine of x.
And what are we left with?
We're left with the limit as
x approaches 0 of cosine
of 2x over 2 cosine of x.
Well what's cosine of 0?
Cosine of 0 is 1, right?
So cosine of 2 times 0,
which is 0, that's also 1.
So that is equal to 1 over--
right, cosine of 0 is
1 --over 2 times 1.
So it equals 1/2.
There you go.
I think those are three
fairly meaty limit problems.
And if you know that, you're
probably prepared for something
that your calculus teacher
might throw at you.
See you in a future video.